It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. There's a story by Tillie Olsen in which a mother of five stands at an ironing board contemplating a note from a teacher asking her to come in and discuss her oldest daughter. "She's a youngster who needs help," the note says, "and whom I'm deeply interested in helping." The mother mulls this over. Should she go in? What is there even to say about her daughter's life? Here's Tillie Olsen, reading.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。蒂莉·奥尔森写过一个故事，故事里一位五个孩子的母亲站在烫衣板前，看着老师寄来的一张字条，请她去学校商量大女儿的事。“那个孩子需要帮助，”字条上写着，“我非常希望能帮到她。”这位母亲陷入了沉思。她该去吗？关于女儿的生活，她又能说些什么呢？下面由蒂莉·奥尔森亲自朗读。
Even if I came, what good would it do? You think because I'm her mother, I have a key? Or that, in some way, you could use me as the key? She's lived for 19 years. There's all that life that has happened outside of me, beyond me.
即使我去了，又有什么用呢？你以为我是她母亲，我就掌握着一把钥匙吗？或者你觉得，不管怎样，你可以利用我作为钥匙？她已经活了19年了。她的人生中发生过那么多事，都在我之外，超出了我的能力范围。
And when is there time to remember, to sift, to weigh, to estimate, to total? I'll start, and there will be an interruption, and I'll have to gather it all together again. Or I'll become engulfed with all I did or did not do, with what should have been, and what cannot be helped.
什么时候才有时间去回想、去筛选、去衡量、去估算、去总结呢？我刚要开始，就会有人打断，我不得不重新整理思绪。或者，我会沉浸在自己做过或没做过的事情中，沉浸在那些本该如此却又无可奈何的事情中。
And then, as she stands there ironing, she reviews her daughter's life, point by point, from the baby she was through all sorts of troubles and mistakes. A working mother trying to be there for her children, trying and learning as she goes, making it up as she goes. Until, at the end, she finally comes to this beautiful passage, this almost encyclopedic list, of everything which can happen with one's children.
然后，当她站在那儿烫衣服时，她逐点回顾了女儿的一生，从她还是个婴儿时，直到经历各种麻烦和错误。一位职业母亲试图陪伴她的孩子，在摸索中学习，在行走中弥补。直到最后，她终于想到了这段美丽的文字，这几乎是一份百科全书式的清单，列出了关于孩子可能发生的一切。
I will never total it all. I'll never come in to say she was a child seldom smiled at. Her father left me before she was a year old. I had to work her first six years when there was work, or I sent her home and to his relatives. She was dark, and thin, and foreign-looking, in a world where the prestige went to blondness, and curly hair, and dimples. She was slow where glibness was prized.
我永远无法总结这一切。我永远不会去说她是一个很少被微笑相待的孩子。她不到一岁时，她父亲就抛弃了我。前六年里，只要有工作我就得去干，要么就把她送到他亲戚家。在这个推崇金发、卷发和酒窝的世界里，她皮肤黝黑、瘦弱，看起来像个外邦人。在推崇伶牙俐齿的地方，她却反应迟钝。
She was a child of anxious, not proud love. We were poor and could not afford for her the soil of easy growth. I was a young mother. I was a distracted mother. There were the other children pushing up, demanding. Her younger sisters seemed to be all that she was not. There were years she did not let me touch her.
她是一个在焦虑而非骄傲的爱中长大的孩子。我们很穷，无法为她提供轻松成长的土壤。我那时是个年轻的母亲。我是个心不在焉的母亲。还有其他的孩子接踵而至，给我施压。她年幼的妹妹们似乎拥有了她所没有的一切。有好几年，她甚至不让我碰她。
She kept too much in herself. Her life was such that she had to keep too much in herself. My wisdom came too late. She is a child of her age, of depression, of war, of fear. Let her be. So, all that is in her will not bloom, but in how many does it? There is still enough left to live by. Only help her to know, help make it so there is cause for her to know that she is more than this dress on the ironing board, helpless before the iron.
她把太多的心事藏在心底。她的生活环境使她不得不如此。我的智慧来得太晚了。她是时代的产物，是萧条、战争和恐惧的产物。随她去吧。所以，她身上的一切可能不会开花结果，但又有多少人能如愿呢？只要还有足够活下去的力量就够了。只要帮助她去了解，让她有理由知道，她不仅仅是烫衣板上那件在熨斗面前束手无策的连衣裙。
Being a parent is an improvisation and things go wrong. As in any daily undertaking, things go wrong. And, in the end, so many mothers feel unappreciated.
做父母是一场即兴表演，事情总会出错。就像任何日常事务一样，总有出错的时候。而最终，许多母亲都感到不被赏识。
Mothers are taken for granted.
母亲们被视为理所当然。
This is, as you'd might expect, a mother. In fact, it's my mother, Shirley Glass. She is a psychologist in Baltimore.
正如你所料，这位是一位母亲。事实上，她是我的母亲，雪莉·格拉斯。她是巴尔的摩的一名心理学家。
Mom, I was wondering if you've noticed that every year since we started This American Life four and a half years ago we've done a Father's Day show, but we've never done a Mother's Day show.
妈，我在想，你有没有注意到，自从我们四年半前开办《美国生活》节目以来，每年我们都会做父亲节特辑，但却从未做过母亲节特辑。
Actually, I never noticed it until you pointed it out to me.
其实，在你指出之前，我从未注意过。
OK.
好吧。
I guess I've become accustomed to ignoring those kind of slights.
我想我已经习惯了忽略这种怠慢。
[LAUGHING] Oh, really?
[笑] 哦，真的吗？
Well, I have a generic answer for that.
嗯，我有一个通用的答案。
You do?
你有吗？
Yeah, why you've done Father's Day shows and you haven't done a Mother's Day show is because mothers are taken for granted.
是啊，为什么你们做父亲节节目而不做母亲节节目，是因为母亲们被视为理所当然。
Like, how do you mean?
比如，你是怎么理解的？
Well, for example, I knew somebody who told me that the summer that he was at camp and his mother wrote to him every single day. And his father wrote to him once. And he kept the letter that his father sent for the rest of his life because it meant so much. And he didn't keep any of the letters that his mother sent.
嗯，比如，我认识一个人，他告诉我他小时候去夏令营，他母亲每天都给他写信。而他父亲只写过一次。他把父亲写的那封信珍藏了一辈子，因为它意义重大。但他没有留下母亲写给他的任何一封信。
Well, is that because it was so surprising that his father would be emotionally expressive? Whereas his mother was always emotionally expressive?
那么，那是因为父亲表达情感太让人惊讶了吗？而母亲总是情感丰富的？
Exactly. The child is so secure with the mother that he doesn't need to hold onto a souvenir or a symbol that she cares about him.
正是如此。孩子对母亲感到非常安全，以至于他不需要留着纪念品或象征物来证明她关心他。
Hm.
嗯。
That's what I just said, that we take the mothers for granted.
这就是我刚才说的，我们把母亲视为理所当然。
Well, obviously, some mothers believe that mothers are taken for granted. Today on our program, we try to right this terrible wrong in our small, little way, here on the radio, with stories for Mother's Day. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, you're listening to This American Life's Mother's Day show.
显然，有些母亲认为母亲们是被理所当然对待的。今天在节目中，我们尝试以我们在电台这点微不足道的方式来纠正这个可怕的错误，为大家带来母亲节的故事。从芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共电台，您正在收听《美国生活》的母亲节节目。
Our program today in three acts. Act One, "She Said, She Said," in which Alex Blumberg conducts an investigation, perhaps the first ever, with people who compulsively imitate their mother's voices in everyday conversation, well into adulthood. Act Two, "Are You My Mommy?" When a 14-year-old was sent into adult prison in Florida, the state did such a terrible job taking care of her that, incredibly, several women, an embezzler, a convicted murderer, and some thieves, stepped in to mother her. That story from writer Alex Kotlowitz. Act Three, "Mom Music." Beau O'Reilly confronts his mother about her dirty little secret with Johnny Cash. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，“她说，她说”，亚历克斯·布伦伯格进行了一项调查，这可能是史无前例的，对象是那些在日常对话中强迫性地模仿母亲声音的人，即使成年后依然如此。第二幕，“你是我的妈妈吗？”当一名14岁的女孩在佛罗里达州被送进成人监狱时，州政府照顾她的工作做得如此糟糕，以至于令人难以置信的是，几名女性——一名贪污犯、一名定罪的杀人犯和几名窃贼——介入其中，像母亲一样照顾她。这个故事来自作家亚历克斯·科特洛维茨。第三幕，“妈妈音乐”。博·奥莱利就她与约翰尼·卡什之间的小秘密与母亲对质。请继续收听。
Act One, "She Said, She Said." There are, as far as we can tell, no scientific studies proving what we're about to assert to you. Our evidence is anecdotal and preliminary. We invite the scientific community to pick up the thread where we leave it. Our findings, thus far, are these. We have discovered that there is a vast subset of American families that crosses all social classes in which the children do imitations of their mothers all the time, even into adulthood. What does it mean? Alex Blumberg tells all.
第一幕，“她说，她说”。据我们所知，没有任何科学研究证明我们接下来要向你断言的事情。我们的证据是轶事性的和初步的。我们邀请科学界在我们结束的地方继续研究。我们目前的发现是这样的。我们发现存在一个涵盖各社会阶层的庞大的美国家庭子集，其中的孩子一直在模仿他们的母亲，甚至到了成年以后。这意味着什么？亚历克斯·布伦伯格将揭晓这一切。
In my un-scientific survey I can tell you this, it's always people who have close relationships with their mothers, whose mothers are still powerful forces for them, who end up imitating them. What's always striking is how vivid these imitations are.
在我的非科学调查中，我可以告诉你这一点，总是那些与母亲关系密切、母亲对他们而言依然具有强大影响力的人，最终会模仿她们。令人惊讶的总是这些模仿是多么生动。
My name is Gianofer. I'm from Milwaukee. And the typical conversation with my mother, or my favorite thing to imitate her, is in the morning, when we were children, she'd come in the room to wake us up. And there were three girls in the room. And so she would come in every morning and she would first wake up my sister, Sharon. And Sharon was the hardest one to wake up.
我叫吉安诺弗。我来自密尔沃基。和我母亲的典型对话，或者说我最喜欢模仿她的内容，是在早上。当我们还是孩子时，她会走进房间叫我们起床。房间里有三个女孩。所以她每天早上进来，会先叫醒我妹妹莎伦。莎伦是最难叫醒的一个。
And so, every morning, she would come in the room and she'd go, "Sharon. Sharon? Sharon? Sharon. Sharon. Sharon! Sharon, I know you hear me talking to you, Sharon. Sharon, get up. Sharon, I'm going to wake up the rest of the babies trying to wake you. Sharon, get up. Lord, I don't know how you don't want to get-- Sharon. I know you-- Sharon? I wish you would get out of that bed! Girl, get up!" And that was every morning. And it would always start off very sweet. "Sharon? Sharon. Sharon. Sharon." And it's not Sha-ron, it's, Sharn. Sharn Sharn.
所以，每天早上，她会走进房间说：“莎伦。莎伦？莎伦？莎伦。莎伦。莎伦！莎伦，我知道你在听我说话，莎伦。莎伦，起床。莎伦，我要把其他的宝贝都吵醒来叫你起床了。莎伦，起床。天哪，我不知道你怎么就不想——莎伦。我知道你——莎伦？我真希望你赶紧从那床上下来！姑娘，起床！”这就是每天的早晨。而且开始总是很甜。“莎伦？莎伦。莎伦。莎伦。”而且不是Sha-ron，是，Sharn。Sharn Sharn。
She talked all the time. If you would say that, you know, "I'm studying now." "Oh, you studying? What you studying? Let me look at that book. And we didn't have books. See, we didn't have books like this when I was in school, Jonna. We had a little, old slate. And you'd put your name on there with some chalk. And then, when you were done, you'd just wipe it right off. That's how that worked back then, Gianofer."
她不停地说话。如果你说，“我现在在学习。”“哦，你学习？你学什么？让我看看那本书。我们没有书。你看，乔娜，我在学校时可没有这样的书。我们只有一块小小的旧石板。你在上面用粉笔写上名字。然后，当你写完后，你就把它擦掉。那时候就是这样工作的，吉安诺弗。”
Gianofer's been imitating her mother since she was four or five years old. She says, originally, it was to be mean, to mock her. Her mother talked so country, she says. But then, she started imitating her mother for a different reason after her father got sick. She was different, her mother was different.
吉安诺弗从四五岁起就开始模仿她母亲。她说，起初是为了刻薄，为了嘲笑她。她说她母亲说话太土了。但在她父亲生病后，她开始因为不同的原因模仿她母亲。她变了，她母亲变了。
Her voice actually changed during that time period. It came not so much out of her throat, but from her heart. Because, I think, she thought that everything she would say, particularly to him, may be the last thing. And so her voice actually changed during that time period. Her voice got very low. It wasn't, "How you doing Gianofer?" It was, you know, "Gianofer, how are you," because everything was just, you know, "Lord, don't know." Everything was just so hard and so trying. "And I just--"
那段时间她的声音确实变了。它不是从嗓子里发出来的，而是从心里。因为，我想，她认为她说的每一句话，特别是对他说的话，可能是最后一句。所以那段时间她的声音确实变了。她的声音变得很低沉。不是“你好吗，吉安诺弗？”而是，“吉安诺弗，你好吗，”因为一切都只是，“天哪，不知道。”一切都太难、太折磨人了。“我只是——”
And then she would always say, that she hardly ever said before, "I just don't know. You know I don't know what," you know, "he's just getting so sick lately." And then everything started to sound like that. Even if I call her now, "How you doing?" "Well, I'm doing fine. Everything's all right." And she whispers a lot more now. Even though people she's talking about aren't in the house, she'll whisper. "I think she's going to come over tomorrow and help me with my puzzles."
然后她总是会说以前很少说的话，“我真不知道。你知道我不知道什么，”她说，“他最近病得越来越重了。”然后一切都开始听起来像那样。即使我现在打电话给她，“你好吗？”“噢，我挺好的。一切都好。”她现在说话总是低声细语。即使她谈论的人不在屋里，她也会压低声音。“我想她明天会过来帮我做拼图。”
During the whole, I would say, last year of his life she was taking care of him, but we were taking care of her. So you spent a lot of time talking to her and talking to my siblings about her. So, I think, when we got to the point where we were always calling each other-- and my phone bill was, like, $300 or $400 during this whole time period, month after month-- we would imitate her to each other. But it was more of a way to relay this information in a way that didn't hurt so bad.
在这一整年，我会说，在他生命的最后一年，她照顾他，但我们也在照顾她。所以你花了很多时间跟她说话，跟我的兄弟姐妹谈论她。所以，我想，当我们经常互相打电话时——在这整个时期，月复一月，我的电话费大约是300或400美元——我们就会互相模仿她。但这更多是一种以不那么痛苦的方式传达信息的方法。
It was easy for me to call my brother up, or my sister up, and say, "You know, Toots doesn't like anything." We call her Toots. You know, Toots is complaining about this. "And the grass ain't cut. Now, I wanted my grass cut at 4 o'clock. You know, David didn't show up until 4:30. I had to push that lawnmower by myself." It wasn't so hard to hear then.
我很容易给哥哥或姐姐打电话说，“你知道，嘟嘟对什么都不满意。”我们叫她嘟嘟。你知道，嘟嘟在抱怨这个。“草还没剪。我本想让他在4点钟剪草。结果大卫4点半才出现。我不得不自己推那台割草机。”那时候听起来就没那么难受了。
I always wonder, and I think my siblings always wonder, is it as bad as she says it is, or isn't it? And so, by imitating her and trying to get it as close to it as possible, it is conveying more information, you know? "David didn't cut that grass til 4:30," is a lot different than, "Lord, David didn't cut that grass til 4:30. I just don't know what I'm going to do." When her voice is like that, it's just like, oh my, somebody get there now. But if it's, "I don't know why that boy didn't cut that grass," she's fine. She's complaining, she's fine.
我一直很纳闷，我想我的兄弟姐妹也一直很纳闷，事情真的像她说的那样糟糕吗？所以，通过模仿她并尽可能接近原样，这传达了更多信息，你知道吗？“大卫4点半才剪草”和“天哪，大卫4点半才剪草。我真不知道该怎么办才好”完全是两码事。当她的声音是那样时，感觉就是，噢天哪，得有人赶紧过去。但如果是“我不明白那孩子为什么没剪草”，她就没事。她在抱怨，她没事。
In our family, we always imitated our mother to each other.
在我们家，我们总是互相模仿母亲。
Another thing I can tell you, if one person in the family imitates the Mom, everybody does. Take Julia Sweeney's family.
我还能告诉你的另一件事是，如果家里有一个人模仿妈妈，所有人都会模仿。看看朱莉娅·斯威尼的家庭。
It was actually a main source of bonding between the kids, of us telling each other stories of something she said or did to each other.
这实际上是孩子们之间建立联系的主要方式，我们互相讲述她说过的话或做过的事。
OK. For example?
好的。举个例子？
My sister, Meg, who lives in Japan, if she and I are talking about my mother, she'll say, "Well, I called Mom and Dad last week, and Dad's reading more books about dogs. And he's still considering getting a dog, and we had a great talk about that. And then Mom said, 'Well, I don't know why you chose to move 10,000 miles away. A person who decided to move 10,000 miles away from their family must have some reasons for moving. And you should think about that, why you need to be 10,000 miles away.'"
我住在日本的妹妹梅格，如果她和我谈论我的母亲，她会说，“嗯，我上周给爸妈打电话了，爸爸在看更多关于狗的书。他还在考虑养条狗，我们聊得很开心。然后妈妈说，‘嗯，我不知道你为什么选择搬到10000英里之外。一个决定搬到离家10000英里远的人一定有什么原因。你应该想想，为什么你非要待在10000英里之外。’”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And then we'll laugh because one of the reasons you are 10,000 miles away is because someone near you could be saying things like that to you. [LAUGHS]
然后我们会笑，因为你搬到10000英里之外的原因之一，就是因为身边有人会对你说这种话。[笑]
My mom used to do these things like, she had weird, confusing-- it's kind of like with the money thing-- confusing gift. Like, she would say, "For your birthday, I'm going to give you $50 towards that $200 microwave I want you to have."
我妈以前总是做这些事情，比如，她有奇怪的、令人困惑的——就像钱那件事一样——令人困惑的礼物。比如，她会说，“为了你的生日，我要给你50美元，买下那个我希望你拥有的200美元的微波炉。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And then you'd say, "Well," [LAUGHING] "Then I have to spend $150 on the microwave, and I don't even want that microwave." And she'll say, "No, I've checked out all the microwaves. I've gone to Sears. I've gone to The Bon. I've gone everywhere. This is the microwave for you to have. But I have a budget on your birthday for $50. So I thought, if I put down the first $50, you could pay it off over time. And then that would be my birthday gift to you."
然后你会说，“好吧，”[笑]“那我得花150美元买微波炉，我甚至根本不想要那个微波炉。”她说，“不，我已经看过所有的微波炉了。我去了西尔斯百货。我去了博百货。我到处都看过了。这就是你应该拥有的微波炉。但我给你准备的生日预算是50美元。所以我认为，如果我先付50美元，你就可以分期付清。那就算是我送给你的生日礼物了。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I think part of it is to offset what may be uncomfortable with a funny way of imitating something that, if you weren't imitating, it might be just plain upsetting otherwise.
我想部分原因是把可能不舒服的事情用一种幽默的模仿方式抵消掉，如果你不模仿，换做其他方式可能会让人感到非常难过。
Really?
真的吗？
Well, you know, it's just easier because it distances you from the person, and then you can imitate them and then look at them as a funny way. In some ways what your brain is saying is, "I'm not them. I'm so not them. I'll make a character that's them and say what they would say as them. That's how much I'm not them." You know? Like that.
嗯，你知道，这更容易，因为它让你与那个人保持距离，然后你可以模仿他们，把他们当作一种有趣的方式来看待。在某种程度上，你的大脑是在说，“我不是他们。我绝不是他们。我会创造一个角色，模仿他们，用他们的身份说出他们会说的话。我就是这么坚定地认为我不是他们。”你知道吗？就是那样。
Julia Sweeney is an actress. And for years, when she was just starting out, she would assume the character of her mom in sketches with The Groundlings Comedy Troupe in LA. But, when her mom came to see the shows, she'd pull the sketches. It was the same when she was on Saturday Night Live . One skit was based on this idea.
朱莉娅·斯威尼是一名演员。多年来，当她刚起步时，她会在洛杉矶Groundlings喜剧团的短剧中扮演她母亲的角色。但是，当她母亲来看演出时，她会撤掉这些短剧。她在《周六夜现场》时也是一样。其中一个短剧就是基于这个想法。
My mother would always tell-- it's actually, it's so funny to me. She tells you the story of a movie from the point of view of the character who is most like her in age and point of view in the movie, no matter how small that character is in the movie.
我母亲总是讲——对我来说这太搞笑了。她从电影中那个年龄和观点与她最相似的角色角度来讲电影故事，无论那个角色在电影中有多么微不足道。
So, if it was Romeo and Juliet, say, she would say, "I saw a movie about this nurse. And she takes care of this girl, who's 14, who's very rambunctious and hard to manage. And she's had a hard time controlling her. And she runs off with a boy that no one wants her to be with. And everyone tells her she doesn't know what she's talking about. And the nurse is very concerned about this girl. And, of course, they end up dead at the end."
所以，如果是《罗密欧与朱丽叶》，她说，“我看了部关于护士的电影。她照顾一个14岁的女孩，非常顽皮，难以管教。她很难控制她。而且她跟一个没人希望她交往的男孩私奔了。每个人都告诉她，她不知道自己在说什么。护士非常担心这个女孩。当然，最后他们都死了。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so I was going to do this on SNL. And then I just couldn't. I was too nervous about-- I just didn't want her to see it. I wanted to protect her.
所以我本来要在《周六夜现场》演这个。但后来我就是没法演。我太紧张了——我只是不想让她看到。我想保护她。
Eventually, Julia's mother did see herself on stage in Julia's one-woman show, God Said Ha! Even after several years, her mother still recalls certain scenes she took offense at, which Julia understands. Mothers have feelings.
最终，朱莉娅的母亲确实在朱莉娅的单人表演《上帝说哈哈！》中看到了自己的影子。即使过了几年，她母亲仍然记得某些让她感到受冒犯的场景，这朱莉娅很理解。母亲也是有感情的。
On the other hand, I have to say it's a way of loving them and enjoying them, maybe, in the only way you can. Because I have a huge amount of love for my mother, and I really enjoy her, but one way I think I learned to enjoy her was to make her a character to me that was also funny.
另一方面，我不得不说这是一种爱她们、享受她们的方式，也许是以你唯一能做到的方式。因为我非常爱我的母亲，我真的很享受她，但我认为我学会享受她的一种方式，就是把她变成一个对我来说也很有趣的角色。
And sometimes my mother says incredibly insightful, true things. And maybe it was a way for me to feel more intimacy with her in some weird, inside-out, perverted way, by making her into a character, and then relating to her as that character, and, in some ways, even allowing that character to have really true insights.
有时我母亲会说出极其深刻、真实的话。也许这是一种让我感到与她更亲近的方式，用某种奇怪的、颠倒的、扭曲的方式，通过把她变成一个角色，然后与那个角色建立联系，在某种程度上，甚至允许那个角色真正拥有深刻的洞察力。
One of the paradoxes of imitating your mother is that you expose certain aspects of her personality in precise detail, or you simplify and make cartoon-ish her personality as a whole. Sarah Koenig, whose mother was born overseas and still has her British accent, says it's because the portrayals leave huge chunks out.
模仿母亲的悖论之一是，你精确地揭示了她性格的某些方面，或者你简化并将其性格作为一个整体变得卡通化。莎拉·科尼格说，她的母亲出生在海外，至今仍有英国口音，这是因为表演遗漏了巨大的部分。
I think the character of my mother that I play is sort of more dotty and sort of talking all about, "Well, I went to the fish shop. And they didn't have enough tuna, so I got the swordfish. And I don't have the right-- it's so irritating," you know, this kind of bumbling, silly, English woman.
我认为我演的母亲角色更古怪，总是谈论，“嗯，我去了鱼店。他们没有足够的金枪鱼，所以我买了剑鱼。而且我没有合适的——这太让人恼火了，”你知道，这种笨拙、傻气的英国女人形象。
And she's actually not really like that. She is really impressive in what she's had to deal with in her life. So I don't know if that comes through. That's probably missing. And I don't know how you make that come through. I mean, I don't know if you can bring that out in any kind of dopey imitation of your mom.
而她实际上并不是那样的。她在处理生活中的事情上非常令人钦佩。所以我不知道这一点是否通过表演传达出来了。这可能被遗漏了。我不知道怎么能把这一点呈现出来。我的意思是，我不知道你是否能通过任何那种愚蠢的模仿来展现你母亲的一面。
She's always trying to get you, or my brother, or my sister to do chores by-- she bills them as fun because we'll do it together. She'll say, "Oh, Sarah, can't you just help me in the garden a bit?" [LAUGHS] And I'll say, "Oh, Mom, please, I don't want to. Can we do it a little later?" "Oh, Sarah, it's so much fun when we do it together." And she gets a lot of flack for that.
她总是试图让你，或我哥哥，或我妹妹做家务——她把它包装成乐趣，因为我们可以一起做。她说，“噢，莎拉，你不能帮我在花园里干点活吗？”[笑] 我会说，“噢，妈，求你了，我不想。我们能晚点再做吗？”“噢，莎拉，我们一起做多有意思啊。”她因为这个受到很多指责。
Why does she get flack for that?
为什么她因为这个受到指责？
Because it's such a ruse, so clearly a ruse. It's not fun. And sometimes they were bad jobs. "It's so much fun if we do it together."
因为这太诡计了，显然是个诡计。那一点也不好玩。而且有时那是很糟糕的工作。“如果我们一起做会很有趣的。”
[TELEPHONE RINGS]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
Hello, Mrs. Matheson? This is Alex.
喂，马西森太太吗？我是亚历克斯。
Oh, hello Alex.
哦，喂，亚历克斯。
Well, it seemed unfair not to consult the real protagonist of this story. I called Sarah's mom, and it turns out she knows Sarah's imitation quite well.
嗯，不咨询这个故事的真正主角似乎不公平。我给莎拉的妈妈打了电话，结果她非常了解莎拉的模仿。
I would make my usual little homilies of when we were gardening. And I would try to entice them to help me and say, "Now, let's do it all together. It'll be such fun." [LAUGHS] And Sarah would say this back to me with a little slant. And I realized that I was sounding absurd. Although, I wished they would come and help me. And I do think it's more fun when we do it all together.
我们园艺时，我会说我那些惯常的劝说的话。我会试图引诱他们帮我，说，“现在，让我们一起做吧。会很有趣的。”[笑] 莎拉会带着一点讽刺模仿我。我意识到我听起来很荒谬。虽然，我希望他们能过来帮我。而且我确实认为我们一起做更有趣。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In fact, Sarah and her mother both remember a time when Sarah didn't do imitations, when she was too afraid of her mother to even attempt them. And they both remember the exact moment when everything changed.
事实上，莎拉和她母亲都记得莎拉不模仿的那段时光，那时候她太害怕她母亲，甚至不敢尝试。她们都记得一切改变的确切时刻。
My sister and I would fight, which we did all the time, loudly, violently occasionally. And, one time, my sister and I were fighting horribly. We must've been, like, 10 and 12, or nine, and then, nine and 12, or something.
我和姐姐会打架，我们总是那样，大声地，偶尔会暴力地。有一次，我和姐姐吵得不可开交。我们那时大概是10岁和12岁，或者9岁，9岁和12岁什么的。
I couldn't stand the wrangling any longer, the fighting. It was endless and always, wrangling and fighting, until it drove their poor mother berserkers.
我再也受不了那种争吵了，打架。没完没了，总是争吵打架，直到把她们可怜的母亲逼疯。
I remember exactly where it was in the house, in this tiny, little alcove where there was a phone. I mean, there wasn't even room for the three of us. And my mother got so fed up that she grabbed my sister and me by the collar, kind of.
我记得那是在房子里的确切位置，在一个有电话的小壁龛里。我的意思是，甚至没有我们三个人的空间。我母亲受够了，她抓住我和姐姐的衣领。
And then I threatened them. And said that I would bang their heads together if they didn't stop. And they didn't stop, so I banged their heads together.
然后我威胁她们。我说如果她们不停下，我就要把她们的头撞在一起。她们没停下，所以我真的把她们的头撞在一起了。
And then, what happened?
然后，发生了什么？
And they laughed. That's what they did.
她们笑了。她们就是这么做的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And we started laughing, uncontrollably. It was so absurd. And you could see she wanted to laugh, but she couldn't. It was this critical moment of discipline, and she couldn't.
我们开始无法控制地大笑。这太荒谬了。你能看出她想笑，但她笑不出来。那是一个至关重要的管教时刻，她不能笑。
I was really shocked. I was guilty and horrified, and I was mad as well.
我真的很震惊。我感到内疚和恐惧，我也很生气。
I think the realization, at that moment, was we both knew that my mother was never going to discipline us the same way, ever again. Like, that there would be no more corporal punishment around the house because it was too absurd.
我想，那一刻的觉悟是，我们都知道母亲再也不会用同样的方式管教我们了。比如，家里不会再有体罚了，因为这太荒谬了。
I became, from a feared and authoritarian mother, to a figure of fun. And, suddenly, nothing worked.
我从一个可怕的、独裁的母亲，变成了一个搞笑的人物。突然间，一切都不管用了。
I went from being afraid of her wrath to mocking her wrath. [LAUGHS] And she knows it, she talks about it. That's another thing she says all the time, "It's so awful." She says, "You wait 'til you have children and you go from a figure of fear to a figure of fun."
我从害怕她的愤怒变成了嘲笑她的愤怒。[笑] 她知道这一点，她总是提起它。这是她总是说的另一件事，“这太可怕了。”她说，“等你有孩子，从恐惧的化身变成搞笑的化身，你就知道了。”
By making the things that I thought important, or wanted to make important, absurd, it freed her. I do think that.
通过让我认为重要、或想让它变得重要的事情变得荒谬，这解放了她。我确实这么认为。
And it freed her from what, exactly?
它到底解放了她什么？
Well, you know, I'm a sort of overbearing person, and it's hard for them to get away. Sarah, at one point, said to me when she came back from Moscow and I was trying to have her make tea. And she didn't want to have tea. I have tea every afternoon, I'm a creature of habit. And those sorts of habits irritate her, that I'm very habit-bound. And I said, "You're very disagreeable. You've come all the way from Moscow," and, et cetera. And she said, "Well, don't you understand? I can't bear to be here, and I want to be here all the time."
嗯，你知道，我是个有点专横的人，他们很难逃脱。莎拉有一次从莫斯科回来，我试图让她泡茶。她不想喝茶。我每天下午都喝茶，我是个习惯成自然的人。而那种习惯激怒了她，我太墨守成规了。我说，“你真不讨人喜欢。你从莫斯科大老远回来，”等等。她说，“嗯，你不明白吗？我不忍心待在这里，但我又想一直待在这里。”
I think that this form of diverting me from my purpose is very good for me because it makes me see myself in a different way. And sometimes it's very loving, and it makes me relax and not want to control all the time. It's taken me a long time in order to give up that control, and it's a great relief. I mean, keeping control is very exhausting, I think.
我认为这种让我偏离目标的做法对我很有好处，因为它让我从不同的角度看自己。有时这非常有爱，它让我放松，而不是一直想控制一切。我花了很长时间才放弃这种控制，这是一种极大的解脱。我的意思是，保持控制非常令人筋疲力尽，我认为。
You know how everyone--- there's this maxim that we all become our mother or we all become our parents. And, generally, I really wouldn't mind becoming my mother. I really like her, so I wouldn't mind becoming her. But I definitely need to edit her. And, I think, if I imitate her and I'm making fun of her, those are the parts of her that I would edit out of myself. If I have to become her in the long-run, then I'd like to not become those parts. If I can isolate those bits and repeat them frequently, perhaps I can avoid them.
你知道每个人都知道的那条格言——我们最终都会变成我们的母亲或父母。总的来说，我真的不介意成为我的母亲。我真的很喜欢她，所以我不介意成为她。但我绝对需要编辑她。我想，如果我模仿她并取笑她，那些就是我想要从自己身上删除的部分。如果我长期必须成为她，那么我希望不要成为那些部分。如果我能隔离那些点并频繁重复它们，也许我就能避免它们。
Which brings me to my last finding, imitating your mom doesn't mean you don't get along with her. Gianofer talks to her mom on the phone almost every day. Sarah recently went with her mom to a health spa in the desert for a week and actually found it relaxing. And Julia just spent 10 days with her mother in Spokane and came back with nothing she wanted to mock.
这引出了我的最后一个发现，模仿妈妈并不意味着你不和她和睦相处。吉安诺弗几乎每天都和她妈妈通电话。莎拉最近和她妈妈在沙漠的健康疗养院住了一周，甚至觉得很放松。朱莉娅刚刚和她母亲在斯波坎呆了10天，回来时没有想嘲笑的内容。
Alex Blumberg is one of the producers of This American Life .
亚历克斯·布伦伯格是《美国生活》的制片人之一。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "YOUR MOTHER'S HERE TO STAY" BY ALLAN SHERMAN]
[音乐播放 - 艾伦·谢尔曼的《你的母亲会留在这里》]
Well, coming up, who makes a better mother, a convicted criminal behind bars or the state of Florida? Answers in a minute. From Public Radio International when our program continues.
好吧，接下来，谁能成为更好的母亲，是铁窗后的罪犯还是佛罗里达州政府？稍后揭晓。节目继续，来自国际公共电台。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, stories for Mother's Day. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是母亲节特辑。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, "Are You My Mommy?" Tougher sentencing laws all across the country have resulted in more teenagers being bumped up from juvenile court to adult court, where they get adult sentences. And if you're, say, 14, and get sentenced to serious time like this, in most states, you will serve the first few years of your time in a juvenile detention center, someplace designed for young people, where they'll make you go to school, where there are facilities for you and people trained to deal with you.
第二幕，“你是我的妈妈吗？”全国各地更严厉的量刑法律导致更多的青少年从少年法庭被推向成人法庭，在那里他们获得成人量刑。如果你14岁，被判处这样的长期监禁，在大多数州，你将在少年拘留中心服刑最初的几年，那是为年轻人设计的，那里会让你去上学，有为你准备的设施和受过培训的人来处理你。
But, in some states, you can get sent, right away, to adult prison from the start. 7,000 young people are in adult prisons right now. And, of course, in that situation, the state has taken on the job of being your parent. And it isn't always such a good parent. Alex Kotlowitz has the story of one teenage girl who was sent to adult prison in Florida. And the prison did such a sloppy job caring for her-- it wasn't set up for this job after all-- that other prisoners stepped in to mother her.
但是，在一些州，你一开始就可能被直接送进成人监狱。现在有7000名年轻人身处成人监狱。当然，在这种情况下，州政府承担了你父母的角色。但它并不总是那么好的父母。亚历克斯·科特洛维茨讲述了一个被送进佛罗里达州成人监狱的少女的故事。监狱在照顾她方面做得非常马虎——毕竟它没为此做好准备——以至于其他囚犯介入并像母亲一样照顾她。
Jessica Robinson is a slender girl with emerald green eyes, her hair on this day styled in a short bob. Her forehead is marked by a light case of acne. We met in an office at the Dade Correctional Institution, a sprawling prison complex which lies on the edge of Florida's everglades.
杰西卡·罗宾逊是一个瘦削的女孩，有着翠绿的眼睛，那天她的头发梳成了短波波头。她的额头上有一些轻微的痤疮。我们在戴德惩教所的一间办公室里见了面，这是一个巨大的监狱综合体，坐落在佛罗里达大沼泽地的边缘。
We sit in chairs knee-to-knee. Jessica stretches, arching her back. She answers many of my questions with the phrase, "Yes, but no." She cracks her knuckles. She yawns. She snatches a piece of paper from the desk and rolls it up tightly. She picks lint off of my microphone. She tugs at the hem of her prison-issue navy blue skirt. She is, to put it mildly, fidgety. "Were you scared when you first got to prison?" I asked.
我们膝盖对着膝盖坐着。杰西卡伸展着，拱起背。她用“是，但不是”这句话回答了我的许多问题。她掰着指关节。她打着哈欠。她从桌上抓起一张纸，紧紧地卷起来。她捡走我麦克风上的绒毛。她扯着她那条监狱发放的海军蓝裙子的下摆。轻描淡写地说，她很不安分。“你刚进监狱时害怕吗？”我问。
Scared when I went in Jefferson? No.
进杰斐逊时害怕吗？不。
What are things you miss the most?
你最怀念什么？
Having fun.
玩得开心。
Like what?
比如什么？
Going out with Barbara, mainly. Because we used to go to the beach and stuff. Going shopping, oh I miss shopping. Going to the movies, going to the pet shops, seeing the little puppies in the windows.
主要是和芭芭拉一起出去玩。因为我们过去常去海滩什么的。去购物，噢，我怀念购物。去看电影，去宠物店，看到橱窗里的小狗。
If you could get out tomorrow, what would be the first thing you'd do?
如果你明天能出去，你第一件事会做什么？
I don't know, I'd probably go to Taco Bell and eat.
我不知道，我可能会去塔可钟吃点东西。
Go to Taco Bell?
去塔可钟？
Yep. I love Taco Bell.
对。我爱死塔可钟了。
Jessica is 16, the youngest prisoner here at Dade. She's a girl among women. She's been in prison, adult prison, for two years and is serving a nine-year sentence for armed robbery and kidnapping. But I'll get to that shortly.
杰西卡16岁，是戴德监狱里最年轻的囚犯。她是女人中的女孩。她已经在监狱，成人监狱，呆了两年了，因为武装抢劫和绑架正在服9年刑期。但我很快会谈到这一点。
In July of 1998, Jessica arrived at her first stop after the county jail, the Jefferson Correctional Institution, an all-women's prison near Tallahassee. She was 14. She had long, dirty blond hair that fell to the small of her back, and she was reed thin. Shortly after her arrival, she met Suzanne Manning, who's serving 30 years for embezzlement.
1998年7月，杰西卡到达了县监狱后的第一站，杰斐逊惩教所，塔拉哈西附近的一所女子监狱。她当时14岁。她留着一头脏金色的长发，垂到腰部，瘦得像根芦苇。到达后不久，她遇到了苏珊·曼宁，她因贪污罪正在服30年徒刑。
The first time I ever saw Jessica, it was actually sitting in the child hall at Jefferson Correctional Institution. There had been a lot of rumors going around about this little girl that was at Jefferson. And Jefferson's considered kind of a tough prison. And there are three gun towers. It's pretty intimidating. It's very strict, you walk in a little yellow line on the side of the walkways.
我第一次见到杰西卡，其实是坐在杰斐逊惩教所的儿童大厅里。关于这个在杰斐逊的小女孩有很多传言。杰斐逊被认为是一个比较严厉的监狱。有三个枪塔。这相当令人生畏。它非常严格，你走在走廊边上的一条黄色小线上。
So, in the child hall, I had heard all the rumors. Well, when I saw her walk by, I was in shock because, when you looked at Jessica-- and this was years ago now, a couple of years ago-- Jessica looked like a child. Her cheeks were rosy red, she still looked like she had baby fat on her. And she looked totally lost. Not too long after I first saw her she moved into my dorm, in B Dorm. And my heart just broke when I saw Jessica and I got to talk to her because she was a child, she was a baby, and she was thrown into this hellhole and didn't have a clue.
所以，在儿童大厅里，我听到了所有的传言。好吧，当我看到她走过去时，我震惊了，因为当你看着杰西卡——那已经是几年前的事了，几年前——杰西卡看起来像个孩子。她的脸颊红扑扑的，看起来还有婴儿肥。她看起来完全迷失了。我第一次见到她后不久，她就搬进了我的宿舍，B宿舍。当我看到杰西卡并能和她交谈时，我的心都碎了，因为她还是个孩子，她还是个婴儿，她被扔进了这个地狱，却一无所知。
Suzanne Manning's 39. She's a handsome woman. Her six years in prison have turned her curly hair gray. She became the first in a line of women to watch over the 14-year-old.
苏珊·曼宁39岁。她是个漂亮的女人。她在监狱里的六年使她卷曲的头发变白了。她成了那一连串看着这个14岁女孩的女性中的第一个。
Well, I thought I would start helping her with some school work. We went to the library, and they had kind of a children's section. And Jessica ran over and got a book, The Little Mermaid , and wanted me to read that book to her. And I think it brought out a lot of my maternal instincts because my son was 13 when I came to prison, and I missed a lot of those times with him. So being able to sit and read with Jessica, it really did both of our hearts good.
嗯，我想我可以开始帮她做点学校功课。我们去了图书馆，他们有一个儿童区。杰西卡跑过去拿了一本书，《小美人鱼》，想要我给她读那本书。我想这激发了我很多母性，因为我进监狱时我儿子13岁，我错过了他很多时光。所以能坐下来和杰西卡一起阅读，这对我们俩的心灵都很好。
Jessica was born in Austin, Texas. Her father was a heroin addict and, according to Jessica's mother, Teresa, he physically abused her and their two daughters.
杰西卡出生在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。根据杰西卡的母亲特蕾莎的说法，她父亲是个海洛因成瘾者，经常身体虐待她和他们的两个女儿。
When Jessica was three, Teresa fled from Miami to be near her parents. There, she waitressed nights at Denny's and, by her own admission, wasn't a very patient mother. She and Jessica fought frequently.
杰西卡三岁时，特蕾莎带着她逃离迈阿密，去投奔父母。在那里，她晚上在丹尼餐厅当服务员，而且据她自己承认，她并不是一个很有耐心的母亲。她和杰西卡经常吵架。
When Jessica turned 13, she began to run away from home, once, staying away for three weeks. She was detained in a juvenile facility on three occasions, all a result of inter-family squabbles. Once she threw a plate at her older sister. Another time she bit her mother on her hand.
杰西卡13岁时，开始离家出走，有一次失踪了三周。她因家庭纠纷三次被拘留在少年管教所。有一次她向大姐姐扔了盘子。另一次她咬了她母亲的手。
Teresa told me she'd called the juvenile authorities hoping she could get her daughter psychiatric help, but she had no health insurance. Indeed, a psychologist who saw Jessica in detention recommended that she be placed in a residential program where she could receive therapy. Nothing ever came of that suggestion. She was released a few days later.
特蕾莎告诉我，她给少年管教部门打电话是希望能给女儿心理治疗，但她没有医疗保险。事实上，一名在管教所见过杰西卡的心理学家建议她参加一个可以接受治疗的居住项目。那个建议从未落实。几天后她就被释放了。
At one point, Teresa sent Jessica to live with her grandparents, but Jessica quickly alienated them as well. She argued with them, and they too called the authorities. Jessica sought revenge.
有一次，特蕾莎送杰西卡去和祖父母住，但杰西卡很快也疏远了他们。她和他们吵架，他们也报了警。杰西卡寻求报复。
On a late Saturday night in July of 1997, Jessica, who was 13, and two other teenagers, a boy and a girl, showed up at her grandparent's. Jessica and the other girl snatched jewelry and cash while the boy forced the two grandparents at knife point into a back room, ordering them to kneel on the floor. The boy threatened to kill them with a flower pot and, at one point, cut the grandfather on the hand. The three were arrested a couple of days later.
1997年7月一个深夜，13岁的杰西卡和其他两个青少年，一个男孩和一个女孩，出现在祖父母家。杰西卡和那个女孩抢走了珠宝和现金，而男孩强迫两个祖父母用刀指着进入后屋，命令他们跪在地上。男孩威胁要用花盆杀了他们，有一次还划伤了祖父的手。三天后这三人被捕。
Under Florida law, the state's attorney could choose to prosecute Jessica as an adult, and did, charging her with armed kidnapping and armed robbery. Jessica pled guilty. Her mother wasn't present for the sentencing. She'd married a serviceman and followed him to Germany.
根据佛罗里达州法律，检察官可以选择以成人身份起诉杰西卡，他也确实这么做了，指控她武装绑架和武装抢劫。杰西卡认罪。她母亲没有参加判刑。她嫁给了一个军人并随他去了德国。
In court, Jessica initially refused to apologize to her grandparents. And at the sentencing, the judge told Jessica that her dogs were better behaved than her. The judge also told Jessica, and I quote, "I don't think we need people like you in our country." She sentenced Jessica to nine years. Jessica became the youngest girl in Florida's adult prisons. Suzanne Manning then entered Jessica's life.
法庭上，杰西卡起初拒绝向祖父母道歉。在判刑时，法官告诉杰西卡，她的狗比她表现得更好。法官还告诉杰西卡，我引用一下，“我不认为我们的国家需要你这样的人。”她判处杰西卡9年徒刑。杰西卡成了佛罗里达成人监狱中最年轻的女孩。苏珊·曼宁随后进入了杰西卡的生活。
I couldn't imagine being a child growing up-- I knew what my son, at the age of 13, was eating when I left home, and I knew how important snacks were. I knew how important chips were, and juice when he wanted it. And then, all of a sudden, to realize, here's this child in prison who couldn't eat when she wanted to eat. And, sure, everyone would chip in and buy Jessica snacks and stuff, but do you know what it's like to feed a child like that on $30 a week? I mean, it's virtually impossible. We used to look at her at night thinking, what can we do to get food for her? It was horrible.
我无法想象一个孩子长大——我知道我儿子13岁时在吃什么，我知道零食有多重要。我知道薯片有多重要，他想要果汁时有多重要。然后，突然间，意识到，这里有一个在监狱里的孩子，想吃的时候却吃不到。当然，每个人都会凑钱给杰西卡买零食什么的，但你知道每周花30美元喂养那样一个孩子是什么感觉吗？我的意思是，这几乎是不可能的。我们过去常在晚上看着她，思考着，我们能做些什么来为她弄到食物？那太可怕了。
Prisons are pretty strict on touching. It's called unauthorized physical contact, and you can get a DR, disciplinary report, and go to confinement for it. And, many times, officers would catch me hugging Jessica, or rubbing her head, or her head on my shoulder if she was crying, and they wouldn't say anything, they'd just walk past it. And I understand that they couldn't encourage it, or acknowledge that they saw it without having to write me up because they would have to keep the rules for everybody. There is not a rule that says if you're 14 or 15 someone can hug you because you need a hug.
监狱对身体接触非常严格。这被称为未经授权的身体接触，你可能会因此得到一份纪律报告，并被关禁闭。很多时候，警卫会抓到我拥抱杰西卡，或者揉揉她的头，或者如果她在哭，她的头靠在我的肩膀上，他们什么也不会说，只是走过去。我明白他们不能鼓励，也不能在不写纪律报告的情况下承认他们看到了，因为他们必须对每个人遵守规则。没有一条规则说如果你14或15岁，有人可以拥抱你，因为你需要一个拥抱。
But they would let you?
但他们会让你这样做吗？
Many times. Many, many times. There was one time in our dorm, when I walked in, everyone got real quiet, and a little circle was formed around, in the back around people. And Jessica was in the center of it in an argument. I didn't even recognize her voice, OK? She was in an argument with this girl and they were just going at it. And this circle had been surrounded around them by adults who wanted them to fight. And I actually got between two of the women, and I took Jessica and pulled her up to the officer's station.
很多次。很多很多次。有一次在我们的宿舍里，当我走进去时，每个人都安静下来，后面围成了一个小圆圈。杰西卡站在圆圈中央，正在争论。我甚至认不出她的声音，好吗？她和那个女孩在争吵，她们正在针锋相对。这个圆圈被想看她们打架的成年人包围着。我实际上走到了两个女人中间，我把杰西卡带到了警官的岗位上。
Now, let me guess, Jessica must've really pissed at you.
现在，让我猜猜，杰西卡一定对你非常生气。
Well, in the beginning, she was. I'm not going to say she wasn't. She told me that she needed to prove her point, and she needed to stand up, and all the rest of those con words. But she didn't need to do it. And she ended up being OK after that.
嗯，一开始她是。我不会说她不是。她告诉我她需要证明自己的观点，她需要站起来，以及所有那些罪犯的套话。但她不需要那样做。在那之后她最终也没事了。
Christmas was really big for her. She said she could remember Christmases with her mother. And I remember one Christmas, one of my friends named Susan made Jessica-- she melted down some Hershey bars and made Jessica a Christmas tree out of Hershey bars that were melted. She mixed some nuts in it. And then she took M&M's and smashed them up and put them on top to make it like it was lights, and shaped it all up and got it hard, and gave Jessica that.
圣诞节对她来说非常重要。她说她能记得和母亲一起过的圣诞节。我记得有一个圣诞节，我一个叫苏珊的朋友为杰西卡做了一些——她融化了一些好时巧克力棒，为杰西卡做了一棵由融化的好时巧克力棒组成的圣诞树。她混入了一些坚果。然后她拿了一些M&M豆捣碎，放在上面当作灯光，把它们全部塑形并弄硬，送给了杰西卡。
And I ran out to the store. I thought of it at the last minute. I hadn't even thought that she was a child and it was Christmastime and she might want something. So I ran out to the store and I got Jessica a radio and some headphones and some batteries. When I came back down, and I gave that to Jessica, she didn't stop hugging me. She jumped up and down.
我跑去商店。我最后一刻才想到这件事。我甚至没想过她还是个孩子，那是圣诞节，她可能想要什么东西。所以我跑去商店给杰西卡买了一个收音机、耳机和一些电池。当我回来，把那个交给杰西卡时，她没停止拥抱我。她高兴得蹦蹦跳跳。
And then I realized what a solace that was to her to be able to listen to the music. I mean, she stayed on her bed after that and didn't bother us, pretty much. She could listen to music. She knew what was going on. She walked around with it at rec. And I thought, why didn't I think of that before? She's a child. Children like music.
然后我意识到能够听音乐对她来说是一种多么大的慰藉。我的意思是，在那之后她就呆在床上，没再打扰我们，差不多。她可以听音乐。她知道发生了什么。她在娱乐时间带着它到处走。我想，我怎么没早想到呢？她还是个孩子。孩子们喜欢音乐。
Jessica started calling Suzanne Mommy, but Suzanne discouraged her.
杰西卡开始叫苏珊妈妈，但苏珊劝阻了她。
She started that, "Mom, you're my mom." And I sat down and told her, "I'm not your mom. Your mom is in Germany. And I'm Suzanne, and I'll do anything I can to help you." And a lot of people think that's cruel. I don't think it is. I think it's a reality. I'm not your mom.
她开始那样，“妈，你是我的妈妈。”我坐下来告诉她，“我不是你的妈妈。你妈妈在德国。我是苏珊，我会尽我所能帮助你。”很多人认为这很残忍。我不认为。我认为这是现实。我不是你的妈妈。
Another reality is, if you try to be in groups like that or bond like that with people here, in prison, you get shipped. I mean, you can get shipped today. This morning they could've woken me up and said, "You're going to Dade." On Tuesday, they could wake me up and say, "You're going to Lowell." Jefferson had one shipment day, and that was Tuesdays. People were shipped on Tuesdays. So, every Monday night, I'd say, "Jessica, do you realize that I can be shipped tomorrow? Do you realize you can be shipped tomorrow?"
另一个现实是，如果你试图在像这里这样的团体里，或在这里，在监狱里与人建立那样的联系，你会被送走。我的意思是，你今天就可能被送走。今天早上他们本可以把我叫醒说，“你要去戴德了。”周二，他们本可以把我叫醒说，“你要去洛威尔了。”杰斐逊有一个转运日，那是周二。人们在周二被送走。所以，每个周一晚上，我都会说，“杰西卡，你意识到我明天可能会被送走吗？你意识到你明天可能会被送走吗？”
Suzanne was transferred to another prison. But, before she left, she wrote to the Children's Advocacy Center at Florida State University's law school detailing her concerns about Jessica. Jessica needs more milk, Suzanne wrote. Jessica receives a prison diet tailored for a grown man or woman. It includes only one cup of 2% milk each day.
苏珊被转移到了另一所监狱。但在她离开之前，她写信给佛罗里达州立大学法学院的儿童倡导中心，详细说明了她对杰西卡的担忧。苏珊写道，杰西卡需要更多的牛奶。杰西卡得到的监狱饮食是为成年人量身定做的。每天只包括一杯2%的牛奶。
Claudia Kemp was a law student at Florida State, and she took on Jessica's case. Claudia is 47, a former hardware store owner and the mother of three daughters. She made a commitment to see Jessica every week. And, pretty soon, she'd become the second woman to step in as a kind of surrogate parent to Jessica.
克劳迪娅·肯普是佛罗里达州立大学的一名法学院学生，她接手了杰西卡的案子。克劳迪娅47岁，前五金店老板，三个女儿的母亲。她承诺每周去看杰西卡。很快，她就成了第二个介入并成为杰西卡代孕家长的女性。
One time she was not feeling well. And she just put her head down on the table and said, "I want you to take me home with you."
有一次她感觉不太好。她只是把头埋在桌子上说，“我想要你带我回家。”
And you said?
然后你说？
And I said, "I wish I could." I mean that I wish I could take you out of here. I'm sorry you're here. Other times she would say, you know, "Couldn't I just go out for a drive?" "Can I go to the beach? I wish I could just go to the beach." And it's not even that she was asking to be let out, but just couldn't I go out for a little while, like a field trip. It's sort of what she was asking for, was a field trip. Just to go out. And it was very hard because you have to repress a very natural reaction.
我说，“我希望我可以。”我的意思是我希望我能把你从这里带出去。我很抱歉你在这里。其他时候她会说，“我难道不能出去兜兜风吗？”“我可以去海滩吗？我希望我能去海滩。”她甚至不是在要求被释放，只是能不能让我出去一会儿，就像一次实地考察。这就是她所要求的，一次实地考察。只是出去一下。这非常困难，因为你必须压抑一种非常自然的反应。
Which is?
是什么？
To want to take care of her. She had never been to the visiting plaza, which is the visiting that happens on the weekend when people's families come, because she never had any family to come. So she had never participated in that visiting schedule. And so I made arrangements to come see her on a Saturday.
想要照顾她。她从未去过探视广场，那是周末家属来访时发生的探视，因为她从来没有家人来过。所以她从未参加过那种探视日程。所以我安排在周六去看她。
And a friend of hers grandparents were also there on that same day, so it was like a party that we had. I stayed there for four hours. And Jessica and her friend made us lunch, which is another one of these recipes they have where they take a variety of items from the canteen, like Spam, and oriental rice with seasoning, and Cheetos, and they make this almost-- I'm not even sure what to call it-- like a little cornmeal roll of some kind.
她一个朋友的祖父母那天也在那里，所以就像我们举办了一个聚会。我在那里呆了四个小时。杰西卡和她的朋友为我们做了午餐，这是她们食谱中的另一种，她们从食堂里拿各种东西，比如午餐肉，带调料的东方米饭，和奇多，她们做成这种几乎——我甚至不知道该怎么称呼它——就像某种玉米卷。
In October of last year, Jessica, for the second time, lost an adult who was looking after her. She was transferred to the Dade Correctional Institution, which is eight hours from Tallahassee, too far for Claudia to visit any more. And Jessica can't write Suzanne Manning since correspondence between inmates isn't allowed. Here at Dade, which houses 521 women inmates, Jessica has found other mentors, which she describes as her prison family.
去年10月，杰西卡第二次失去了照顾她的人。她被转移到了戴德惩教所，离塔拉哈西有8小时车程，太远了，克劳迪娅无法再去看她。而且由于不允许囚犯之间通信，杰西卡不能给苏珊·曼宁写信。在这里，在关押着521名女性囚犯的戴德监狱，杰西卡找到了其他导师，她称之为她的监狱家庭。
I have two dads, two moms. I have a great grandfather, a great grandmother, uncles, aunties, brothers, cousins, sisters.
我有两个爸爸，两个妈妈。我有曾祖父，曾祖母，叔叔，阿姨，兄弟，表亲，姐妹。
And, as a family, do they watch out for you?
作为一个家庭，他们会照顾你吗？
Yeah, they do.
是的，他们会。
Her prison family is such an elaborate affair that two of her moms, their nicknames Blackie and Tattoo, both in for murder, had a custody battle over Jessica. I didn't ask Jessica how the dispute was settled, but suffice it to say that Blackie won and Tattoo is granted visiting rights on Wednesdays and Sundays.
她的监狱家庭是一件如此复杂的事情，以至于她的两个妈妈，绰号布莱基和纹身，都是因谋杀入狱，为了杰西卡进行了监护权争夺战。我没问杰西卡争端是怎么解决的，但可以肯定的是布莱基赢了，纹身获准在周三和周日有探视权。
Her family gave her a Sweet 16 party, making a cake out of Pop Tarts, cream cheese, and melted chocolate. One woman made a Teddy bear out of socks, which Jessica took to bed every night until it was discovered by a guard and confiscated. Stuffed animals aren't permitted.
她的家人为她举办了一个甜蜜16岁派对，用Pop Tarts糕点、奶油干酪和融化的巧克力做了一个蛋糕。一个女人用袜子做了一个泰迪熊，杰西卡每天晚上都带着它睡觉，直到被一个警卫发现并没收了。不允许带毛绒玩具。
Who do you go to here for advice?
你在这里找谁征求建议？
My great grandfather, Sarah Allen. She's 21. She's in my dorm. She lives in my dorm.
我的曾祖父，莎拉·艾伦。她21岁。她在我的宿舍。她住在我宿舍。
Wait, she's 21, and she's your great, great grandfather?
等等，她21岁，是你的曾祖父？
She's just my great grandfather. Yeah, only 21.
她就是我的曾祖父。是的，才21岁。
Her great grandfather, Sarah Allen, is in for killing a 40-year-old man in a hold-up. One mom, Blackie, along with an accomplice, robbed an elderly couple at their home. The accomplice hacked them to death with a machete. Another mom, Tattoo, along with an accomplice, stole checks from an elderly gentlemen. Her accomplice beat the man to death. These are the women now in Jessica's life. During my visit at Dade, I met with Jessica's prison step-mom, Wanda Dennis, who's serving 22 months for check forgery.
她的曾祖父，莎拉·艾伦，是因为在一次抢劫中杀死了一个40岁的男人入狱的。一位妈妈，布莱基，伙同同谋，抢劫了一对老夫妇的家。同谋用砍刀将他们砍死。另一位妈妈，纹身，伙同同谋，偷了一个老人的支票。她的同谋把那个人殴打致死。这些就是现在杰西卡生命中的女性。在我访问戴德期间，我见到了杰西卡的监狱继母，万达·丹尼斯，她因伪造支票正在服22个月徒刑。
I will not see anybody harm her or do anything to her. She's a baby. To me, she's a baby. I have a child, what? Two years younger than her? And if one of my kids was to come here, in the same situation as her, I want someone older to look out for my child also. And I look out for her in that aspect, as if she was one of my own children.
我绝不会让任何人伤害她或对她做任何事。她是婴儿。对我来说，她是婴儿。我有孩子，嗯？比她小两岁？如果我的孩子来到这里，处在像她一样的境地，我也会希望有人能照顾我的孩子。我从这个角度照顾她，就像她是我自己的孩子一样。
If she calls you and you do not move right that minute, oh, she blows up and she storms off. She's gone and she's mad. And then, when you see her, "Oh, I don't want no-- you don't never have time for me." And, "No, you have time for everybody else." And we're like, "But, Jessica, we just spent all day yesterday." It doesn't make a difference. Every day is Jessica's day.
如果她叫你而你没有在那一分钟动身，噢，她会爆发并冲走。她走了，她很生气。然后，当你见到她，“噢，我不需要不——你从来没时间陪我。”而且，“不，你有时间陪所有人。”我们就像，“但是，杰西卡，我们昨天才花了一整天时间。”那没区别。每一天都是杰西卡日。
Oh my god. She has this little walk. I think it's her little grown-up walk. And I hate it when she does it. And I tell her all the time, "Stop walking like that." I don't know, I could just picture her walking the compound right now.
噢，天哪。她有这种小小的走路姿势。我想那是她那小小的成熟走路姿势。我讨厌她那样做。我一直告诉她，“别那样走路。”我不知道，我脑海中现在就能浮现出她走在院子里的样子。
But, you say she's got an adult-like walk, you mean just kind of swiveling her hips?
但是，你说她有一种成人式的走路姿势，你是说只是扭动臀部？
Yes, that's the walk she does. Yes. But it's just her own little walk she's picked up since she's been here, I think.
是的，那就是她的走法。是的。但我认为那是她来到这里后自己学会的小走路姿势。
Kind of testing those adult waters, I guess.
我猜是在试探成人的水域。
Yes. Yes. She has, in a way, to me, she doesn't have a choice. She either has to blend in with adults or act like a child. If she acts like a child, then she gets talked about.
是的。是的。她在某种程度上，对我来说，她没得选。她要么必须融入成年人，要么表现得像个孩子。如果她表现得像个孩子，就会被别人谈论。
The fact is, this isn't an environment that leaves much room for experimentation. And Jessica's no longer a rosy-cheeked 14-year-old. She'll be 17 in August. She smokes. She curses. She wears dark eye shadow. She lifts weights. Not surprisingly, she suffers from depression and takes anti-depressants. The women in Jessica's life worry about her.
事实是，这不是一个留有太多实验余地的环境。杰西卡也不再是那个脸蛋红扑扑的14岁女孩了。她8月就17岁了。她抽烟。她咒骂。她画深色的眼影。她举重。毫不奇怪，她患有抑郁症并服用抗抑郁药。杰西卡生命中的女性为她感到担忧。
Jessica's mother, her real mother, has re-entered her life. And she and Jessica have had a reconciliation, of sorts. They talk twice a month. Claudia Kemp, the law student, also keeps in touch by phone with Jessica. She's helped file a motion to get Jessica transferred into a juvenile facility where there'd be teachers, counselors, and therapists to work with her. It's also a place where Jessica could be among other children, which, she told me, is what she misses most of all.
杰西卡的母亲，她的亲生母亲，已经重新回到了她的生活中。她和杰西卡达成了一种和解。她们一个月谈话两次。克劳迪娅·肯普，那位法学学生，也通过电话与杰西卡保持联系。她帮忙提交了一份动议，试图将杰西卡转移到一所少年管教机构，那里有老师、辅导员和治疗师与她合作。这也是杰西卡可以和其他孩子在一起的地方，她告诉过我，那是她最怀念的事情。
Towards the end of our time together, I told Jessica I was planning to visit Suzanne Manning the next day. Jessica excitedly recounted the Christmas Suzanne gave her the radio with headphones. She then paused. "I miss her," she said. Suzanne misses Jessica as well.
在我们在一起的时光快结束时，我告诉杰西卡我计划第二天去见苏珊·曼宁。杰西卡兴奋地讲述了苏珊给她那个带有耳机的收音机的那个圣诞节。她然后停顿了一下。“我怀念她，”她说。苏珊也怀念杰西卡。
I ask all the time. Anybody who comes from Dade, I ask a million questions about Jessica. I heard that right after I left she actually got her GED. Is that true?
我一直问。任何从戴德过来的人，我都会问一百万个关于杰西卡的问题。我听说我离开后不久她真的拿到了GED。这是真的吗？
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
No? I heard that she got her GED. We used to study every night. Even on weekends, we worked on her homework.
没有？我听说她拿到了GED。我们过去常每天晚上一起学习。即使在周末，我们也做她的功课。
It was really hard saying goodbye to Jessica because, I guess, she knew that I was leaving. I mean, it was pretty obvious. And the next morning I went over and said goodbye, and I gave her a hug. And she just sat on her bed and looked at me, like, she couldn't believe I was abandoning her. And that's a pretty painful thing for me to have to deal with.
向杰西卡告别真的很困难，因为，我想，她知道我要走了。我的意思是，那很明显。第二天早上我走过去告别，我给了她一个拥抱。她只是坐在床上看着我，好像，她不敢相信我抛弃了她。这对我来说是一件相当痛苦的事情。
Did she say anything to you?
她跟你说了什么吗？
She said "Goodbye." That was it.
她说“再见”。就这样。
And what were your parting words?
你临别的话是什么？
I told her I loved her and I said goodbye. I said, "Bye, Jessica. I love you," I said, "and you'll be OK." But I don't know that that's necessarily true.
我告诉她我爱她，我说再见。我说，“再见，杰西卡。我爱你，”我说，“你会没事的。”但我不知道那是否一定是真的。
When I asked an official at the Dade Correctional Institution whether it was difficult having such a young girl among adults, he replied, "We treat everyone the same here." That may just be the problem. There's no one, for example, to make sure Jessica goes to school. She stopped attending GED classes because, she told me, "the others in the class were too noisy."
当我问戴德惩教所的一位官员，让一个这么小的女孩在成年人中间是否困难时，他回答说，“我们这里对待每个人都是一样的。”这可能就是问题所在。例如，没有人确保杰西卡去上学。她不再参加GED课程，因为，她告诉我，“班里的其他人太吵了。”
There's no one to stop her from smoking. In fact, her prison family supplies her with cigarettes. There's no one to advise her to think twice before getting a tattoo. She's tattooed the initials of a friend on one finger and, on her forearm, has imprinted the letter M. It was to spell Mom, but, she tells me, she never got around to finishing it.
没有人阻止她抽烟。事实上，她的监狱家庭还给她提供香烟。没有人建议她在纹身前三思。她在手指上纹了一个朋友的首字母，在手臂上印上了字母M。本来是想拼写“妈”（Mom），但她告诉我，她一直没时间完成它。
Alex Kotlowitz is the author of The Other Side of the River and There Are No Children Here . Jessica Robinson gets out of prison in the year 2006.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨是《河的另一边》和《这里没有孩子》的作者。杰西卡·罗宾逊将于2006年出狱。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "IT'S MOM" BY SARAH SELIGMAN]
[音乐播放 - 萨拉·塞利格曼的《是妈妈》]
Act Three, "Mom Music."
第三幕，“妈妈音乐”。
Hello, my name is Beau O'Reilly. And this is my mother, Winifred, here to my right.
喂，我叫博·奥莱利。这是我的母亲，温妮弗雷德，在我右手边。
How do you do? This is my son Richard John.
你好吗？这是我的儿子理查德·约翰。
Oh, no. [LAUGHS]
噢，不。[笑]
And the reason he's laughing is he changed that along the way. He's now Beau, and that's the way he's known. I call him that too.
他笑是因为他沿途改了名字。他现在叫博，大家都这么叫他。我也这么叫他。
And so, Mom, you have 14 children, correct?
那么，妈妈，你有14个孩子，对吧？
Mm-hm. Yes.
嗯。是的。
And it's Mother's Day, and we're here to celebrate Mother's Day.
今天是母亲节，我们在这里庆祝母亲节。
Do you have any memories that you'd like to share?
你有什么想分享的记忆吗？
I was remembering that-- I was thinking about the love part when we made this decision with Ira, that we would go in a love direction. I was thinking about when we were still pretty little and we lived in the house on Edgewood Avenue.
我记得那——我和艾拉做这个决定，我们要走爱的方向时，我在想爱的部分。我在想当我们还很小，住在埃奇伍德大街那所房子里的时候。
Yes.
是的。
And I remember being really little and figuring out, at a certain point, that you listened to the opera on Saturday mornings.
我记得我还很小，在某个点发现，你周六早上听歌剧。
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
And that, if I was interested in opera, I could spend more time with you. Because everybody else was not interested. They were running around outside, which was a reasonable thing for them to do. And so I would come and sit by the radio. And you would listen to the opera. And you would tell me a little bit about the Italian or the German, what the language meant. But you would mostly tell me the story of the opera. And I really didn't care very much about the music, but I loved hearing you tell the story of how the opera worked.
如果我对歌剧感兴趣，我就能和你在一起多待一会儿。因为其他人都不感兴趣。他们在外面跑来跑去，这对他们来说是很合理的做法。所以我就过来坐在收音机旁。你听歌剧。你偶尔会给我讲讲意大利语或德语的意思。但你大部分时间是给我讲歌剧的故事。我其实不太关心音乐，但我很喜欢听你讲歌剧是如何运作的。
Thank you. I hadn't heard that before. My memory of listening to the operas on Saturday afternoon is more I would put the little gate up, which we had when each little child was in the crawling stage. And I'd put the gate up, and I'd say, "I'm going to be in the living room listening to the opera. If you want to be quiet and listen, you can come in. If you want to make a lot of noise and have fun, stay out." [LAUGHS]
谢谢。我以前没听过这个。关于周六下午听歌剧，我的记忆更多是我会竖起那个小栅栏，每个孩子在爬行阶段我们都有那个。我会竖起栅栏，我会说，“我会在客厅听歌剧。如果你想安静地听，你可以进来。如果你想吵闹玩耍，就呆在外面。”[笑]
Right, because it was your private time.
对，因为那是你的私人时间。
It was my private time.
那是我的私人时间。
Yeah. And the private time thing was really important to me when I was a kid, to get private time with you, because I was always surrounded by brothers and sisters, because the place was so small and we all were there all the time. And so I remember, actually, I would calculate little things. Like, OK, am I sick enough to stay home with mother?
对。我小时候私人时间对我来说真的很重要，能和你拥有私人时间，因为我总是被兄弟姐妹包围，因为地方太小，我们所有人都一直呆在那里。所以我记得，实际上，我会计算一些小事。比如，好的，我病得足以留在家里陪妈妈吗？
And there was this period of time, when I was in 5th, 6th grade, something like that, where I would get this stuff that would come out of my eyes. I don't know what it was, it was probably an infection. And I would wake up with my eyes glued shut from this gunk in my eyes that would glue them shut. And I would lie on the bunk bed with these slices of cucumber. You would give me slices of cucumber. And I'd lie on them with the cucumber on my eyes, which, I guess, pulled the stuff out of the eyes. And then you would slip me slices of cucumber to eat. And you would tell me different stories and talk about things. And that is when I remember that you confessed to me your love of Johnny Cash.
有段时间，我在五年级、六年级时，大概是那样，我眼睛里会流出一些东西。我不知道那是什么，可能是感染。我会早上醒来，眼睛被那种粘液糊住。我会躺在双层床上，敷着黄瓜片。你会给我黄瓜片。我躺在那儿，眼睛上敷着黄瓜，我想，这把眼睛里的东西吸了出来。然后你会给我递黄瓜片吃。你会给我讲各种故事，谈论各种事情。就是那时候我记得你向我坦白了你对约翰尼·卡什的爱。
My goodness.
我的天。
Because you would listen to Johnny Cash on the radio. And you were kind of like, "Well, it's country music, and it's kind of dorky, and the rest of us shouldn't know about the Johnny Cash thing. But I really love his voice, Beau." And I loved that about you, that you had this little secret Johnny Cash thing.
因为你会听收音机里的约翰尼·卡什。你当时就像是，“嗯，这是乡村音乐，有点书呆子气，我们其他人不该知道关于约翰尼·卡什的事。但我真的很喜欢他的声音，博。”我很喜欢你那一点，你有个关于约翰尼·卡什的小秘密。
There was a time when I, of course, for many, many years, I would be up in the middle of the night feeding a baby. But there was nothing else on the radio but the Barn Dance.
当然，有好多年，我会在半夜起来喂孩子。那时候收音机里除了《谷仓舞》什么都没有。
Right, it was late at night.
对，那时候很晚了。
And I thought, "Now, these are real people. I don't know this music at all, this country music, but I like the integrity I'm getting here. I like this feeling." And, of course, it also helped me through the night.
我想，“现在，这些人是真人。我一点也不了解这音乐，这种乡村音乐，但我喜欢我在这里得到的正直感。我喜欢这种感觉。”当然，它也帮我度过了夜晚。
Yeah. Well, the singing was always, really, a very important part for you. And, then, therefore, for us. And that was a lot of what we did, as a group, is that we sang together and told stories. Do you want to sing now?
嗯。唱歌对你来说一直是非常重要的一部分。因此，对我们来说也是。那是我们作为一个群体做的很多事，我们一起唱歌，讲故事。你想现在唱吗？
I was thinking that this is a lullaby. I sang it frequently. [SINGING] Lullaby and goodnight, with roses bedight, With lilies o'er spread is baby's wee bed. Lay thee down now and rest, may thy slumber be blessed. Lay thee down now and sleep, may thy slumber be deep.
我在想这是一首摇篮曲。我经常唱。[歌唱] 摇篮曲和晚安，玫瑰装饰，百合花铺开是宝宝的小床。现在躺下休息，愿你的睡眠被祝福。现在躺下睡觉，愿你的睡眠深沉。
I was just thinking about this the other day, is that-- I think I was in the 7th grade because I was already tall, because I was as tall in 7th grade as I am now. So I was, like, 5' 9", and I was very skinny, but I was that tall. And I woke up one morning in the attic. I slept in the attic with my brothers. And I got out of bed and I fell down on the floor because my leg, my right leg, didn't work. It just went completely numb and didn't work. But, somehow, the decision was made I would go to school anyway. The leg must be asleep, and it would wake up, and I would go.
前几天我一直在想这个，——我想我当时在七年级，因为我已经很高了，因为我七年级时就和我现在一样高了。所以我大概5英尺9英寸，非常瘦，但我有那么高。我一天早上在阁楼醒来。我和兄弟们睡在阁楼。我起床，掉在地板上，因为我的腿，我的右腿，没法动了。它完全麻木了，没法动。但不知何故，决定还是让我去上学。腿一定是睡着了，它会醒过来，我就能去了。
So, I went to school. And I got to school on the bus, which was, maybe, two miles from where we lived, two and a half miles. And when I got to school, it was obvious that the leg still wasn't working. It just wasn't working. And so one of the nuns called you and, I think, at the neighbor's house because we didn't have a phone. And the neighbor went and got you.
所以，我去了学校。我坐公交车到学校，距离我们住的地方大概两英里，两英里半。当我到学校时，很明显那条腿还是动不了。它就是动不了。所以其中一个修女给你打了电话，我想是在邻居家里，因为我们没有电话。邻居去把你叫来了。
And you walked from home to the school to get me. And you came to the classroom and you picked me up. And I still remember how it felt to be picked up, at that point, because you put your arms around me and you picked me up at the trunk, like, at the chest and shoulders. And you pick me up, like this, with your two hands kind of linked together, and picked me up, and a lifted me up, and carried me out of the school.
你从家里走到学校来接我。你来到教室把我抱了起来。我至今记得那时候被抱起来的感觉，因为你搂着我，你在躯干处，比如胸部和肩膀处把我抱起来。你像这样，用两只手链接在一起把我抱起来，把我抬起来，带出了学校。
And I was taller than you were, and so my feet dragged along the sidewalk. And I remember that too, the physical sensation of that. And then you carried me from that section of the town to the other section of the town where this doctor was, which is another mile and a half, maybe, maybe two miles. I'm not exactly sure. And you carried me the whole way. And every once in a while you would say, "OK, now honey, we're going to stop." And you would just put me down, and we would wait. And then you would pick me back up and you would go.
我比你高，所以我的脚在人行道上拖着。我也记得那个，那种身体的感觉。然后你把我从镇上的那个部分带到了镇上的另一个部分，医生在那里，那是另外一英里半，可能，可能两英里。你一路都抱着我。每过一会儿你会说，“好了，亲爱的，我们要停一下。”你会把我放下，我们等着。然后你会把我抱起来继续走。
And the whole time you talked to me as we walked, and you told me about your day and what you were doing. And you treated it as if this was just a normal thing. And you made me feel very comfortable with it. And there was no fear in it. And then we went to the doctor. There was nothing really wrong. They sent me home. The next day, it went away. It was this weird little phenomena. But what I remember most about it was that feeling of being taken care of by you. Do you remember that?
整个过程我们走的时候你都在和我说话，你告诉我你的一天和你在做什么。你表现得好像这只是一件正常的事。你让我感觉非常舒服。其中没有恐惧。然后我们去了医生那里。其实没什么大问题。他们送我回家。第二天，它就消失了。这是一种奇怪的小现象。但我记得最深的是那种被你照顾的感觉。你记得吗？
I think I remember it now because I hear you telling it. But I wouldn't have had it in my memory bank until it was brought up. I think that that's what a mother does. A mother takes care of the situation the best she can at the moment and doesn't think of the inability to do it, just I have to do this.
我现在想起来了，因为我听你讲。但在被提起之前，我记忆库里不会有它。我想这就是母亲所做的。母亲在当下尽她所能处理情况，不会去想做不到，只是我必须这么做。
Happy Mother's Day, Winifred.
母亲节快乐，温妮弗雷德。
I don't see how I could have anything else, but a happy Mother's Day.
我不认为我还能有什么别的，除了一个快乐的母亲节。
I love you, Mom.
我爱你，妈妈。
I love you, Beau, Richard John.
我也爱你，博，理查德·约翰。
Beau O'Reilly's play, Not Only Sleeping , is currently in an extended run at Chicago's Curious Theater Branch. Winifred O'Reilly, his musical review that goes up at the end of May in Skokie, Illinois. It's called It's About Time .
博·奥莱利的戏剧《不仅仅是睡觉》目前正在芝加哥Curious剧院分部延长演出。温妮弗雷德·奥莱利的音乐评论，五月底在伊利诺伊州斯基收购演。它叫《是时候了》。
Well, our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike and Consigliere Sarah Vowel. Production help from Todd Bachman and Mary Wiltenburg. Musical help from Mr. John Connors.
嗯，我们的节目今天由布鲁·谢维尼和我自己与亚历克斯·布伦伯格、苏珊·伯顿和朱莉·斯奈德制作。特约编辑，保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。托德·巴克曼和玛丽·威尔滕堡提供制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯先生提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this, or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free, on the Internet, at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买此节目或我们任何节目的盒带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。或者您可以在互联网上我们的网站 www.thislife.org 免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who doesn't know how it happened to him, and he keeps warning me about it.
WBEZ电台由托里·马拉蒂亚进行管理监督，他不知道这件事是怎么发生在他身上的，他一直在警告我关于这件事。
You wait 'til you go from a figure of fear to a figure of fun.
等你从恐惧的化身变成搞笑的化身，你就知道了。
I'm Ira Glass. Happy Mother's Day. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。母亲节快乐。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共电台。